[Music]
now we're gonna prep for our party
because the kids are gonna be here in a
minute
oh so now we can just show you the
stuffer all right I am nervous about the
stuffing machine it's harder than it
looks
and I've never mastered it I'm just
gonna show you how the soap or so you
don't freak out okay well I'm freaking
it already when the kids come up you
tell them okay now step on the magical
pedal and the stuffing comes right out
of here okay oh look at our team is
arrived I love eating
welcome to build-a-bear how are you guys
doing today early excited hey we can get
started with picking out your special
furry friend you have all the bears to
select from go ahead and pick your back
[Music]
then we can head over to the settler
when Lanie says she's gonna put me on
the stuffer machine I'm I'm a little
frightened here we go okay do you know
how to do this all right ready
okay let's go she made it snow like all
the stuffing that should have been
inside that bear it was kind of
everywhere it's in my mouth it's in my
hair and I like hey I knew this what
happened yeah slow it down but then I
was scared to death she was like coming
toward the hair dude is that is that
part of the process I was frightened and
afraid that if she like sort of pulled
on it too hard that my cover might be
blown
you
[Music]
you
[Music]